good morning Hank it's Wednesday off
this reorganization project I thought I
would take your lead and show you my
Saturday the day that YouTube asked all
of us to share our life in a day I got
up around 9 it was raining in Munich and
I didn't have any readings or school
visit scheduled that day so I got on the
train Trane's here and I went into the
city centre because there was this watch
I wanted to get for Sarah and also
because I wanted to get Henry a present
I got off the train of marine plots and
looked around for the store that
supposedly sold the watch I wanted but I
didn't know where the place was I don't
know where the place is
then I found it they were having a sale
that apparently involved price
reductions of undefined percentages I
got the watch I hope she likes it she
liked it so then I walked around looking
for a toy store for Henry I love Munich
and I love being in cities with lots of
other people because I'm reminded that
there are billions of people like me and
we are each stuck inside of our minds
feverishly trying to crawl out to make
connections with other people also I
really like umbrellas it's like I have a
roof I carry it with me umbrellas always
amused me then I came across a bookstore
and I decided to go in they were having
the same vague sale as the other place
not only did they have my books but
while I was in the store I ran into an
actual reader of my books who was there
to pick up an English copy of Paper
Towns I couldn't believe it I was so
excited I had to get video of us
together I've never walked into a book
store even in America and had someone
recognize me when I was looking for my
own books and a little bit embarrassed
but mostly delighted right
now I am looking at a taxicab that
almost hit and killed me but swerved at
the last second thereby saving my life
none of which I caught on video so I
kept looking for a toy store which I
didn't find but I did run into this
women's soccer game in downtown Munich
this guy was watching them play I still
can't tell if his facial expression is
heroic or pervy this sign reminds us
that people with legs of different
lengths should stick together then I
started to vlog about something but
these church bells started up I kept
waiting for them to go away but they
wouldn't they were so loud that I
couldn't even tell where they were
coming from the bells just seemed to be
present which in retrospect I guess is
probably the point anyway eventually I
figured out that the bells were coming
from this church I went inside and that
a candle for a friend of mine who's sick
but I didn't film that because it felt
private and then finally I found a toy
store and I bought Henry a little wooden
train then I got back on the real
training went to my hotel and changed
shirts because I had to do this TV
interview and then I walked over to
white Ravens Book Festival which is why
I was in Munich in the first place
so the Seoul Children's Literature
Festival is at this outrageously nice
castle first built in the 15th century
which is now the largest international
children's literature library in the
world that night there was a hilarious
reading from this book by a guy named
Michel Gerard Bower about a kid called
Ishmael first like a read scenes from
the book in English all on a minute I'll
check I think she's in the shower in the
show and then a German actor read in
German okay so in this very funny book
Michael wrote some song lyrics and then
at the end of the night this miraculous
thing happened a German band made up
mostly of doctors got together and made
the songs for Michael's book real and
then Michael got to sing along which was
of course amazing because the secret
dream of every novelist is to be a rock
star
right
so the English lyrics of this Australian
book come to life inside of a 15th
century castle in Munich and on this day
Hank that's what I loved I loved our
hyper connectedness and our ease of
movement that words written in Australia
can become songs in Germany that the
little stories I write in my basement
can bring me to a place like Munich that
trains and planes and Skype make us all
so close to each other and my fear I
just hope that 500 years from now the
castles that we have made for ourselves
will still be there and that there will
still be people and music and stories to
populate them Hank I got a catalog these
books I'll see you on Friday